uh I can't wait
um but something that maybe you can say
a little bit more although who knows uh
you got to join the Star Wars Universe
yes and um that show I'm really looking
forward to because I may or may not know
some things about it which I will not
say
um but how much fun did you have playing
in that Universe oh my God that was also
really really fun and obviously like the
subject matter is different it's
different when like everything that
you're doing is light-hearted and like
that's not what I was doing for Star
Wars but I was working with my favorite
director that I've watched with so far
coconada and it was just you know under
the leadership of Leslie Headland it is
incredible to see I can't wait to see
how this show turns out Amandla is such
an incredible performer I unfortunately
didn't have any scenes with her but I
got to see a little bit of what they've
been doing and I'm just
I think it's going to be epic and it's
nothing that anyone has seen before
inside of that universe that's exactly
it I'm going to ask you did you get to
hold or use a lightsaber I didn't get
to use a lightsaber got it
but I did
not get to use a lightsaber I understand
completely because I am not a Jedi